I think with the Cody and Jessica
starting out as the prom king and queen
and then you saw them in power and you
saw them kind of be like Mean Girl
couple right power couple to kind of
mean like a little bit like we're so
great a little bit arrogant and then
they turn it around then people are
rooting for them it was so compelling
and it all happened very quickly I think
that is what got people sucked in
Julie Jen sounding off on Big Brother 19
only with et most shocking moment of the
season so far for you I guess that would
be a toss-up between Jessica not taking
Cody up on his offer to fall on his
sword for her and then right behind that
is Cody not insisting that she do it
can't even say they chose love they
chose like temporary loves that only
buys you another how many days in the
house together like you know the rest of
your lives to be together let's be smart
I'm you get the five hundred thousand
they should have just thought about it
and you know ego it's always ego causes
someone's downfall in this game would
you say the worst game of the season was
heard using the hex the week she did
instead of saving it for herself Julie I
am officially unleashing the halting hex
on eviction night there will be no exit
halting hex rise eviction night guys
I've thought about that it's so hard to
predict cuz you know she had she had no
choice it was 50/50 you know who's to
say if she didn't use it what would have
happened down the road so that's a tough
one and she put on such a show about it
yeah yeah and I think she wanted to
stick it to them here's what I meant you
know I'm just really happy that America
decided to give me the final temptation
and then I have the power to keep Cody
and I stay for a few weeks of the three
show manses do you think that's the best
chance of our real relationships outside
the house yes I think that Jess and Cody
are the real deal
the only thing he has to overcome is
because I feel like as a woman watching
he loves this girl
if they end up together she's the boss
of him she she wears the pants in that
relationship and as long as he's like
okay I'll do whatever you say and he
learns to be social with her friends
then they have they have a future but if
he's gonna sit there at the at the clubs
with like the death stare on then her
friends are gonna be like boyfriend am I
gonna have to deal with this in reality
to you just being a hothead getting into
fights with everyone next season season
20 no my god do you believe that 20
seasons how so weird a lot of fans
wanted to be an all-star season from
this season who would you like to see
come back and compete again Cody and
Jess Jessica definitely Jessica's number
one she's someone who has a lot of
followers a lot of people like her she's
smart she's pretty she knows how to play
the game and I feel like she rattles
people you know you either love her or
hate her and that's what you want you
don't want anyone who comes in mild like
oh I don't mind that person you want
someone that people have strong feelings
about and I think she's the one to bring
back what should she do differently if
she comes back and plays what she should
do differently is never say the word
Cody
[Music]